tell me about your life okay outside
your work what do you like to do for fun
what's your passion in life
i am uh a mr fix-it kind of guy i am
known
in the uh jeopardy office as mr
sprinkler man
we have uh
we have a fairly large property that was
heavily landscaped by
the original owner who was a
contemporary of general patton
and he planted all these trees and
plants and everything
and we have between 150 and 200
sprinkler heads
and we they're always breaking and i got
my daughter a new dog a year ago and he
likes to chew them he has
this fascination with black plastic so
he's always chewing the heads off
and my wife says uh one of those
sprinklers is uh on the fritz again
it's shooting 30 feet in the air why
does your wife talk that way
because she's married to me after a
while i didn't realize she's a
prospector
i have that effect on yours
so wait a minute so you're you have 250
sprinkler heads a dog running around
chewing off the tops of them
don't you have a you know uh someone on
the property who does this for you or
this is the kind of thing you like to do
this is the kind of thing i like to do
and the kind of thing that i am good at
i can track down water leaks i have a
very good sense of hearing
and wait a minute you can hear water
leaking
yes you're kidding no
i was wandering around through the yard
one day and
i heard water going through the pipes
and i said there's a water leak and as i
got closer to the house
i said my gosh it's in the house and i
went in the house and sure enough
the connecting uh cable or not cable the
connecting pipe
to one of the toilets had broken and
there were four inches of water in the
guest quarters
so i said thank god see it helps if you
wander your property
alex trebek wanders his large property
and every now and then you're just like
and then you you can sense well
part of that is true but i don't react
that quickly i just go
there's a leak here
[Music]
and then do you start with your hands
digging furiously that's when i call the
dogs over and i tell them dig that up
i'm too old to get on my hands and knees
so they dig it up and i and i repair the
leaks you actually do the plumbing
yourself yeah i love that
really i have bought tools i have more
tools in my
i have no room for cars in my garage
right just tools
wow and uh i enjoy doing that and it's
satisfying
sure i don't know anything about
computers i don't know anything about
cell phones my cell phone has a rotary
dial on it for crying out loud
but if you if you say we have an
electrical problem and i always work
on electrical problems with the power on
which uh what what are you talking about
that's the stupidest thing i've ever
heard you said it earlier
alex you like to live on the edge i
it's a good training for electrocution
no for learning about welding because if
you stick a screwdriver in a certain
place
and it hits the hot wire and touches the
box it gets welded to the box
so you then understand oh that's how you
weld things
so i bought a welder also nice nice so
you turn the power on and you walk
around sticking screwdrivers into light
sockets in your spare time
not in my spare time no i do it whenever
there's a problem that i want to explore
wow
and i like to live on the edge and i
want to do things dangerously everyone
but i've gotten
a little more cautious lately i hope so
yeah i flipped the circuit breaker
right okay very more ways than what i
would very much like to see you at some
point when you're done with the jeopardy
show
start a home improvement show where you
wander your own property with some dogs
looking for leaks and trying to get
electrocuted that would be a great show
my hair grows
get my mustache again you got it that's
the real jeopardy